you know what you want to become a good
American you want to become a citizen we
need to act like us we don't drink I am
Nicolas be with reason TV today we're
talking with Garrett Peck author of the
new book the Prohibition hangover
alcohol in America from demon rum to
cult Cabernet
Garrett thanks for coming thanks next
for having me what is the Prohibition
hangover the idea behind the Prohibition
hangover is to look at what happened to
Americans and alcohol after repeal no
one at all written any kind of study
about what happened with their drinking
habits over this last 76 years and so it
really took a good look at how the
country went from one where we have we
changed the constitution not once but
twice to deal with alcohol and then and
so there was a heavy stigma against
drinking and now here we are 76 years
later where 2/3 of us drink so and those
in the course of just those 3 or 4
generations there was a huge shift in
American society what before prohibition
what was the percentage of Americans who
drank it's kind of hard to say certainly
drinking was actually on the decline
before prohibition in part because of
the century-long temperance movement
broke it actually really peaked in the
1820s that's where probably all-time
peak of American drinking actually time
Williams what was that peak do you know
like how many gallons of person per
child did we try yeah it was about
considered to be three to four times
what we actually drink today okay for
capita it's again so then but we go
along and drinking his declining
prohibition wipes it out officially what
was the percentage of people who kept
drinking during provision we don't
actually know because there were no
statistics that weren't held on during
that time well we do know of course were
deaths from cirrhosis of the liver which
actually plummeted right so in that
sense prohibition worked in 1:1 accounts
right right but then it had you know any
number of negative side effects right
correct such as law breaking wholesale
disobedience to a lot of lint and the
Constitution wrote you know and so on
after prohibition how long did it take
for drinking to become normalized again
I say it really took an probably until
the 1950s and by that point the leaders
in the temperance movement would
prohibition on the country had largely
died off the generation that fought
World War two was the drinking
generation they were born and raised
largely during Prohibition and as they
came of age they decided you know what
this isn't our cause we're going off to
war we're gonna drink and so by the time
you know they drank they drank
watered-down beer right they did that
was part of the soldiers ration that
gonna be - beer which then emanated out
into certain states had three - beer
laws right where younger people could
drink that and then you could get real
stuff later
so the prohibition I mean part of the
book and one of the things that's
fascinating is the way that prohibition
was repealed but then a kind of its
skeleton still exists over the way that
the Whaley liquor is regulated in
America and then also some of our
cultural attitudes could you talk about
how how does it still affect the legal
framework of laws around the country and
then some of the cultural effects of
prohibition from the legal framework the
big hangover we got was the regulatory
framework which was the three-tier
system 32 states and the District of
Columbia adopted the three-tier system
they're called licensed jurisdictions
and then 18 states and Montgomery County
Maryland became controlled jurisdictions
those states in particular and I live in
one of those which is Virginia if you
want to buy distilled spirits you have
to buy it from the state itself even
though you don't buy gas or groceries or
jeans from the state but you buy
distilled spirits from the state so
that's part of it there was such a sense
of the stuff is wrong it's sinful we
want the state to control it how much of
it is us so that we want to capture all
of the proceeds and the tax revenue that
was certainly was part of it and I'd say
today that's entirely the JSC
how calls not a sin anymore in American
society other than a few places in the
deep south so and then what about the
cultural hangover how does how does our
experience with prohibition continue to
inform our fears or anxieties or our
embrace of alcohol yeah the stigma
against alcohol lasted for decades in a
lot of cases it continues still the
existing law decay a lot a lot of places
especially the deep south that I'd say
especially areas where you have a lot of
evangelical Protestants who still preach
the evils
of alcohol so in that sense we have
never ever quite gotten over over
alcohol where does it where does the
where does the vilification of alcohol
come from in a Christian context because
you know certainly there's wine in the
Bible Jesus maybe he didn't drink wine
but he certainly produced a lot of wine
and and obviously Catholics Jews many
Protestant groups didn't have a truck
that didn't have problems with beer or
wine or anything like that what what is
that connection that certain religious
people draw with it it came about and
during the early part of the temperance
movement in 1820s 1830s and these people
were so adamantly in favor of abstinence
they believed that therefore because
they were teetotalers therefore Jesus
had to become one as well and so they
reinterpreted the Bible and said
wherever it says wine it was actually
unfermented wine even though there was
no scientific basis for that whatsoever
or any cultural basis within Judaism but
they had an ideology and therefore that
became a litmus test for them and then
what why did that argument carry over so
widely into an American culture that was
teeming with Europeans who did not have
the same approach you know Latin
Americans Asians or whatever the
temperance movement kind of came head to
head with this huge wave of Catholic
immigrants who brought their drinking
habits with them I mean Catholicism has
never had a theological issue with
alcohol never and the white anglo-saxon
american protestants who were running
the country at the time saw these new
people coming in and saying you know
what you want to become a good american
you want to become a citizen
we need to act like us we don't drink so
a lot of ways this became an attempt for
them to impose their cultural values on
these newcomers into the country mmm
talk about in in the book you you
traveled widely you traveled around the
country talk a little bit about your
travels and talk about the most
interesting place that you saw I
travelled quite a bit I'm actually from
California so when all around I grew up
in Sacramento so we went to
country a lot as a kid and as an adult
probably the most fascinating a trip I
took was the Kentucky Bourbon trail and
the chapter on distilled spirits is
actually my favorite chapter because
it's the one I learned the most about I
went into this knowing the least amount
about bourbon and now I'm a big bourbon
fan just it's such a pretty part of the
country and how to make bourbon and the
aging process is is really fascinating
so is bourbon your poison of choice for
distilled spirits yes but I love beer
and I collect wine so I drink pretty
much everything except for cheap real
vodka is is this a golden age for booze
hams in America I'd say so yeah
especially as there's an increase
awareness of of how we drink it's sort
of there's a big awareness of drinking
and driving and much more people are in
tune with okay if I have to work
tomorrow I can't like have five or six
drinks tonight but so if I get to have
one or two make them really good drinks
right so there's kind of awareness of
that there's the whole foodie culture
that's going on so even despite the
recession people still go to farmers
markets and they want to buy fresh
ingredients and they want to you know
try how to making include those things
in their drinks as well so yeah this is
kind of a cultural phenomenon going on
where people are more addicted to
quality
I want to thank Garrett Peck the author
of the Prohibition hangover for talking
to Reason TV I'm Nicholas
you